[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory today
we're going to be discussing voldemort
the wizarding war and the magical
community in the rest of the world
voldemort was perhaps the most powerful
dark wizard in the history of the
wizarding world he possessed an almost
unbound mastery of magic in one-on-one
combat he was able to effortlessly slice
an opponent's throat without uttering a
word and when his own mortality was put
to test he could evade death time and
time again
so if voldemort was such a menace why
didn't other heroic wizards and witches
from the international wizarding
community volunteer to help fight
against him during that final terrifying
year of the second wizarding war why
didn't any other countries try to help
where were the powerful sorcerers from
mahutukuro in japan all the masters have
won this magic from wagadu in uganda
there were at least 11 wizarding schools
in the world at the time and dozens of
magical governments and each one decided
to leave the defense of britain to a
teenager named harry potter and his
terrified and traumatized classmates
why didn't anyone else help
well today we're going to try to answer
these questions and more
they didn't know
this isn't the best excuse but it
certainly would make sense throughout
the second wizarding war and the years
that preceded it lord voldemort and his
loyal death eaters tried their best to
fight in the shadows having learned
their lesson from their first failed
campaign against the ministry of magic
in the 1970s and 80s voldemort and his
allies knew that their best chance at
success was by placing double agents
within the ministry itself
and if ministry staff didn't want to
work for voldemort out of their own
volition
then the dark wizard was more than happy
to cast the imperious curse on them and
to control their every move through dark
magic
if you think about voldemort's takeover
of the ministry of magic in the final
years of the war this easily explains
why other countries were unaware but if
we turn our attention to those
governments domestic issues we can find
even more reasons
as you might have imagined almost every
government had its own mughal government
and then a separate corresponding
magical government with places like the
uk and the us these dual governments are
pretty easy to see
since we've encountered them in film and
books
there are over 190 muggle countries in
the world but actually in the wizarding
community
some of the magical governments don't
keep the same borders as their muggle
counterparts
in regards to their magical government
some countries actually have entirely
different borders which makes sense
after centuries of warfare
european countries gained and lost
territory fairly often which was
something their local wizarding
communities often chose to ignore
the changing borders of their muggle
nation states were only an annoyance for
the wizards who were content to keep
their traditional holdings which means
there might have been even more magical
ministries than muggle congresses
now you might be wondering what does
that have to do with voldemort well as
you can see there were over a hundred
other wizarding governments and they had
their own domestic issues to deal with
there were likely many other pressing
matters within each and every country
that made up the international
confederation of wizards and maybe just
like voldemort's campaign against the
british ministry of magic many other
countries might have been facing their
own civil wars
even if they had heard the whispers of
voldemort's return
they simply didn't have the power to
investigate it further
voldemort wasn't an international threat
even though lord voldemort was a
terrible threat to the british ministry
of magic he might not have been a worthy
opponent for other countries
even during the first wizarding war when
voldemort led his campaigns against
british wizards and witches the
international confederation of wizards
didn't form any meaningful position
against him
as the wizarding world's version of the
united nations the international
confederation of wizards largest
contribution to the wizarding world was
to keep their people safe
for most of recorded history that meant
creating and agreeing to laws that kept
their true powers hidden from the mughal
populace
but just like the united nations the
international confederation of wizards
also was responsible for resolving
disputes between its member states
so if voldemort were to assume power in
britain and then turn his attention
towards other countries to conquer
it would fall to the international
confederation of wizards to stop him
but according to the few records we have
the international organization never
even convened a committee in order to
discuss a concerted defense strategy
in case voldemort crossed the english
channel it was a domestic affair if you
close your eyes spin a globe and
randomly point your finger to country
you'd have a nine percent chance of
landing on one that is currently
fighting in a civil war
and even though we don't have a complete
list of historical records from the
international wizarding world
it's not hard to imagine that civil wars
and internal strife were all too common
amongst wizards and witches as well
when it comes to muggles many countries
often took a non-interventionist
approach
even though civil wars and strife led to
inconceivable suffering and bloodshed
most civil wars were allowed to proceed
without interference from neighboring
states and the reason was simple
trying to help only made matters worse
worse for the neighboring states and
often worse for the country that was
plunged into the civil war
and that non-interventionist philosophy
was even stronger amongst wizarding
governments the magical congress of the
united states was one of the most
isolationist regimes in the entire world
but its values were shared amongst most
others they simply wanted to protect
their own people from muggle persecution
and didn't want to risk their safety by
openly supporting or challenging warring
parties halfway around the world
hope it didn't spread appeasement if
international wizarding communities
didn't intervene in britain because they
thought it wasn't any of their business
then they must have hoped for one thing
that voldemort's greed didn't extend to
their country
if they were able to appease voldemort
and his death eaters then the
international wizarding community might
be able to avoid open wall which was
always what they feared the most
war between wizards was catastrophic it
was not only tragic for the amount of
lives lost in the conflicts but it also
presented a unique challenge the open
conflict threatened to reveal the
wizarding world to mughals
perhaps foreign governments like the
minister deserve magic de la france and
the magical congress of the united
states of america knew of voldemort's
return and had agreed to not intervene
if the dark lord kept his sights on only
britain
without any proof it's hard to guess at
how likely this policy of appeasement
was
even if there was no formal conferences
between death eaters and foreign
delegations they must have had some sort
of contact with each other
although wizarding governments didn't
like to intervene in the affairs of
others they still needed to keep a close
eye on international events and
voldemort's second rise was certainly
something to watch
they supported voldemort there's one
potential reason that we've yet to
mention and it might be the most
controversial
other countries might have actually
supported voldemort's position
when we look back at the history of the
wizarding community in britain we'll
find a strange tradition
although many of their constituents
prided themselves on being purebloods
the leaders of the wizarding world
actually didn't care that much about
heritage
during the founding of hogwarts school
of witchcraft and wizardry all four
founders initially agreed to let half
bloods and muggleborns enroll in their
school
in fact when salazar therein later
changed his mind and wanted to ban all
but pure bloods from attending the other
three founders refused to consent as you
can see from some of its earliest
history the british wizarding world was
fairly progressive
at least compared to surrounding nations
since we know so much about the history
of wizards and witches in england
calling the british magical community
progressive might sound strange
especially considering their treatment
of goblins but when we extend our look
to the more ethnically homogenous
countries in central europe the middle
east and asia
their policies were far more
conservative and voldemort's position
might not have actually been so
unconventional if we just look at the
mughal government of japan we can find
numerous examples of the hardships that
non-ethnic japanese citizens face and
interestingly treating citizens of
varying ethnicities with equal rights
isn't a great priority or even legally
protected if we apply that same sense of
ethno-national pride to the wizarding
community then the students and
graduates of mahutu koro the wizarding
school of japan might not actually see
the big fuss about voldemort
to them and many other countries around
the world pure blood supremacy might
have been normal
conclusion
in the end we might never know the real
reason that the international wizarding
community failed to help harry potter
and his allies
for my money i'd bet it's an equal mix
of all of these theories many of the
countries might not have seen what the
big fuss was about and others might have
simply not wanted to involve themselves
in a civil war add to that voldemort's
expert coup of the ministry of magic and
foreign ministries could have claimed
ignorance to voldemort's rise
even though they could probably tell
that something was amiss
and that's it for this video what do you
think leave a comment down below until
next time remember it does not do to
dwell on dreams and forget to live
[Music]
[Music]
you